[Musique]
alors on a un Amachi crudo deux salades
niçoises et un barillet
prépare-toi à être très occupé
nous sommes complets ce soir la cuisine
est fermée
allô
je dois beaucoup d'argent combien rayes
tu ne connais pas ces gens ils ne vont
pas nous laisser tranquille comme ça
j'ai 10000 dollars pour la personne
qu'il est sur la route
c'est le sang qui qu'est-ce qui se passe
[Musique]
je travaillais pour le kg
je suis une chef
envoyez-moi tout le monde que vous avez
je me fous complètement du prix mais
faites-les venir à très vite
on va venir à lui des deux côtés c'est
une femme c'est une femme
on peut vous aider tu devrais pas déjà
être couché
il est plus coriace qu'il n'y paraît il
a l'air traiter donc je l'espère pour
lui quand même tu crois pas
[Musique]